preocupación nuclear y conversaciones de
paz fueron las claves de la reunión
celebradas este jueves en el bif
participó Antonio Gutiérrez secretario
general de la ONU
sentido común debe prevalecer para
evitar acciones que podrían poner en
riesgo la integridad física la seguridad
de la planta las instalaciones no deben
ser usadas como parte de ninguna
operación militar en cambios se necesita
un acuerdo urgente que restablezca a
zaporilla como una infraestructura
puramente civil para garantizar la
seguridad de la zona
También estuvo el presidente de Turquía
recepta allí Perdón socio tanto de Rusia
como de Ucrania destacó el papel
mediador de Turquía para levantar el
bloqueo ruso a las exportaciones de
granos de Ucrania
en nuestra reunión tripartita también
evaluamos las posibilidades de
transformar la atmósfera positiva creada
por el acuerdo de Estambul en una paz
permanente el anfitrión del encuentro
fue el presidente de Ucrania abuelo
dimir selensky pese a los avances hacia
la paz sigue exigiendo La retirada rusa
por eso me sorprende oír que ellos
estarían listos para algún tipo de paz
las personas que Asesinan violan todos
los días disparan visibles a nuestras
pacíficas ciudades e infraestructura no
pueden querer la paz Es por eso que
primero que todo ellos deben retirar sus
tropas de nuestro territorio y solo
entonces Primero lo primero
después de seis meses de guerra Rusia no
consigue avanzar más en el este mientras
desde Ucrania dicen que se preparan para
recuperar en claves como gerson y
zaporiya